hey guys welcome back to brand-new buddy
Rebecca I'm foreign again today's
Thursday you are know what's going on
that's your recap today we have some new
information about a new patch coming
next week a technical test for work
where we could play the new heroes and
the new breach mode and some new
ornaments as well as always like the V
if you do enjoy subscribe if you're new
I cover the balance changes in the
informational side a foreigner that
being patch notes balance changes like I
said leaks news all the new hero stuff
all that type of stuff like the cover on
this channel and with that guys let's
get started so first up few tidbits of
information three million people picked
up the starter Edition on PC which is
absolutely crazy and four on our on PC
which means you play in steam is 75% off
for all editions of the game which is
roughly about fifteen dollars for the
base Edition or $25 for the Gold Edition
and the Gold Edition comes with the old
season pass if you do want to place in
PC without having the small hindrance of
the starter edition since the characters
are a little bit more expensive on there
than the base game you can do that while
you can it since as I said it's 75% off
for the next two weeks next up is the
new event order that's going to be
dominant warrior and you need to be the
first faction with the most amount of
Dominion matches completed first place
faction will get 2500 steal second place
will get a thousand five hundred and
third will get 1000 steal next up is the
new content of the week and that's going
to be 5,000 steal it's going to be new
ornaments and these are hero based
ornaments called son cradle and if you
don't know what hero base means that
basically means it's the same warning
but if it has a little bit of a
different variation depending on the
hero you buy I'm gonna keep that in the
background while I keep plugging away
through this video but in the next
couple weeks we should be having a
technical test server on the new breach
mode and new heroes so that it is the
new breach mode we saw at e3 with the
warden Lord type guy and the two new
heroes we talked about which is chianti
in Shaolin not nuke Xia and Jing Zhu
they will probably come later in a
possible future technical test so only
the breach mode and the two heroes we've
mostly been talking about here on the
channel for the past couple weeks the
technical test if you're a little bit
new just means it's our job to basically
play the new heroes and the new mode and
get feedback to the devs so that they
know what needs fixing and changing
before the actual patch goes live it
depends on how much you play and if your
PC is good enough to run it so sadly not
everyone can play this and it is only on
PC hopefully I'll be able to get to play
and get some streams and gameplay for
you guys since I want to have it ever
streamed on PC and hopefully I can get
it even though I am rep one or two so
I'm a little bit low
Rep since I've mostly play council
hopefully the gods of the devs will give
me their beautiful copy of the technical
test regardless so next up is patch 1.25
that's gonna be coming next Thursday on
June 28th pretty short patch nothing too
crazy in it but there's some decent info
to know and first up there's these two
guys and they played a lot of for honor
they're huge best buds one of them sadly
though did pass away from a tragic
accident so the guy so the devs put the
guy's name as a Raider bot in the game
since he does play Raider which is
really touching to hear and if you
happen to go past a Raider bot named the
lizard wizard that is the guy's name
next up for the revenge shield which is
the yellow showed you get when revenge
activates is now 120 HP instead of 70
allowing you to stay alive a lot longer
revive is now four seconds instead of
three as a default with no stats
increased on it and in breach when you
get revived you will only have half
health instead of 100% health this as of
right now is only going to be in that
game mode but they might possibly bring
that to the full game in every other
game mode hopefully when it arrives next
up for all characters a successful
plunging attack or drop attack will not
drop your health to one health it will
actually give you most of your health
back if not all of your health back when
this happens they're also trying to make
matchmaking as flawless as possible am i
matching us with the same rep and same
skill of other players also not taking
10 to 15 minutes to find that specific
mode and then lastly we have one quick
bug fix that was most important and that
was conker can now not full block a
minion and then foil uppercut a player I
have no clue how someone even thought of
this to do this but it's going to be
gone by next week anyway so enjoy that
while you can and then lastly to end the
video the devs talked about the Q&A
about e3 and just other questions that
the community had about the new stuff
coming it in the marching fire update
and one of those is that yes you have to
buy an entirely new season pass to get
the heroes early and for free it's not
required for the characters but it is
easier and more convenient if you buy it
with the season pass you can buy them
with steel and they seem to be the same
price as previous DLC characters which
means they'll probably be about 15,000
steel each I believe or whatever the
price happens to be for those DLC
characters which is kind of sad since
there is four heroes instead of two this
time but the devs have to make their
money somehow
next up other characters will beginning
reworks or balance changes like that
warden unblockable we saw in the breach
trailer and possibly some other
characters my bets personally are going
to be Valcke and shougo key as well
so they will not stop reworking heroes
just because the new marching fire
heroes have released so they're trying
to balance out the cast as much as they
can as quick as they can there is a
breach mode concern that the defense
team will be a little bit unbalanced
compared to the attackers and a little
bit overpowered from their testing it is
not unbalanced whatsoever and even then
we do have the technical test coming up
on PC which will fix any unbalanced
issues as much as they can not
everything can be perfectly balanced
though so they'll try to get it as close
as possible and then lastly is the for
honor speech system which will basically
allow tons of dialogue between heroes
like when your opponent misses an attack
your a character will taunt them for
failing and stuff like that much wasn't
talked about this subject the devs just
wanted to mention in just the case knew
and knew what the new speech thing was
and I personally think this is really
cool to add into the game but that guy
is going to be any to the video
hopefully you guys didn't enjoy it I
could be super appreciated if you did
the devs didn't mention a lot there's
going to be some new stuff coming in the
summer for foreigner so I'll definitely
recap all of that now since I'm
officially done with school and I will
gladly show you any gameplay if anything
happens to become new or changed or
anything like that I'll always recap
before you like I always do subscribe if
you're new like I said I covered the
informational side of for honor that
being balance changes patched nodes hero
updates all that type of stuff like to
cover here on the channel
my two most recent videos will be on the
screen if you guys want to check that
out I think guys so every rest your day
you guys for watching the video
and peace out